شاعره وباحثه اكاديميه واسم بارز في
الاعلام الخليجي والعربي مشوار بدا منذ
عام
1988 ظهرت ملامح الموهبه مبكرا جدا كانت
مؤديه صوتيه ومذيعه في فضائيه البحرين
كانت اصغر قارئه نشرات اخبار رئيسيه
واصبحت مقدمه برامج حتى قبل ان تتخرج من
الجامعه هي علم من اعلام الاعداد والحوار
وتقديم البرامج التلفزيونيه العربيه التقت
في تلك الرحله بالعديد بالعمالقه الادب
والفن والثقافه في الوطن العربي هي عضو
بجمعيه اللغه العربيه رئيسه اللجنه
الثقافيه لنادي خريجي جامعه البحرين
واخيرا حاصله على درجه الدكتوراه في الادب
الحقيقي والنقد الادبي لها عدد من الاعمده
الصحفيه الاسبوعيه والمؤلفات بالاضافه الى
دواوين الشعب الدكتوره فروين حبيب ضيفتنا
اليوم في فقره فنجان قهوه العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنضم الينا في الاستوديو الاعلاميه حبيبي
يسعد صباحك نورتنا شكرا على تواجدك معنا
نورتينا كل صباح العربيه اهلا بك شاعره
ومؤلفه واعلاميه واقل ما يقال عنها وما
توصف بانها ايقونه ثقافيه عربيه نبدا
حديثنا معك بالحدث الان اللغه العربيه ما
الذي تميز هذه السنه بالنسبه لتروين في
هذا اليوم صباح العربيه انا سعيده بان
العربيه هذه عنوان لقناه اليوم همم حقنا
العربيه هذه اللغه التي اعطتنا منحتنا
الكثير رغم اننا يعني كان عندنا بعض
العقوق مع هذه اللغه يعني قصرنا كثيرا
وحتى كادت اللغه هذه تنقرض
حقيقه ان الحدث المهمه قبل اسبوع كان
الاحتفاء باللغه العربيه بيوم اللغه
العربيه بابو ظبي قمه اللغه العربيه في
دورتها الاولى وقد ساعدت انني شاركت همم
وقدمت هذا همم هذه القمه
طبعا هذه كانت بتتعاون بين وزاره الثقافه
وبين همم الشريك الاستراتيجي مركز ابو ظبي
للغه العربيه نعم همم حقيقه يعني كانت
الجلسات جدا مثمره وكان الحضور نوع جدا
جدا في اسماء كبيره من الوطن العربي
تقريبا 31 اسم يعني شخصيات في الفكر في
الادب في حتى في الفنون التشكيليه يعني
مثل ما راينا ادونيس يعني هذه اللقطه
الهاربه يعني وقد جاد واختيار يعني ادونيس
هذه القامه يعني الادبيه وايضا دكتور عبد
الله الغزامي من السعوديه هذا انا اقول
هذا هرم من الخليجي يعني ناقد الكبير
والشخصيه التنويريه وكان في كثير من
الاسماء حتى من الفنانين يعني كان في فنان
سوري المثقف جمال سليمان فكان في حضور
نوعه والجلسات كانت جدا جدا يعني همم فيها
خصوصيه الطرح والهم يعني المهمومين باللغه
العربيه حلوين الجلسه معك لا يمل منها
سنستكمل اسئلتنا معك ولكن قبل ذلك راح
نضيفك بما انه عنوان الفقره فنجان قهوه بس
معنا انه ما بتحب القهوه بتحب الشاي انا
مش قولي انا مش كوفي بيرسون يعني
ما اريد اتكلم بالانجليزي لان احنا سنتحدث
اللغه العربيه اليوم معك همم يعني تفضل
الشاي بروين لا احب العربيه
هل تعتبرين ان لغتنا العربيه في خطر اليوم
امام لغه القران الكريم لا يمكن لها ان
تموت سؤال جدا حلو انا تكلمت في هذا
العمود عندي عمود اسبوعين جريده الامارات
اليوم نلتقي همم العربيا العربيه العربيه
اللغه التي نتكلم بها للاسف نكتب بها يعني
هذه الجيل الان يكتب الحروف همم يعني
الحروف الانجليزيه دقيقه اا ويكتبها
بطريقه عربيه يعني الفظها بالطريقه
العربيه همم يعني يلحنها كانها
فاللغه العربيه احنا ما راح نقول ان هي في
خطر هي سؤال شائك حقيقه يعني انا ما اريد
اتفلسف على المشاهدين صباحا هل هو قلق
اللغه ام قلق اصحاب اللغه يعني لان اصحاب
اللغه احنا نحمل لغه عندها ارث وعندها
ثقافه وعندها ولغه النص المقدسه عندنا
القران الكريم لكن حقيقه مخلينا نكون
شفافين وواضحين اللغه في خطر يعني يوما ما
المفكر والمناظر للحداث العربيه هذه اللغه
ستنقرض وقاموا عليه يعني اقامه القيامه
يعني ادونيس لان هو يرى بعين المفكر هذه
اللغه احنا ما نستخدمها انا كثير من
الاحيان يعني اكون في اماكن عامه في مطعم
او مقهى اشوف يعني بنات من الجيل الجديد
وعرب زين قاعدين يتكلمون طول الوقت
بالانجليزيه
فضول اقتربت من وحده وجبت لها طيب ليش
تتكلمين بالانجليزي ليش طول الوقت يعني
صعبني فضولي فقالت لي احنا نتكلم لان احنا
نشانا ودرسنا وكذا طيب قلت لها طيب هذه
اللغه اذا انتم مارستوها وراح تنقرض راح
تنتهي يعني فعلا قالت لي جمله كثير لفتت
نظري قالت لا ما راح تنتهي الدكتوره لان
هذه لغه القران الكريم طيب سؤال القران
الكريم في البيت يعلوه الغبار لا يمس ولا
يقرا همم كيف ممكن همم هذا النص يفعل هذا
الذكر لحافظون لاننا نزلنا الذكر وان له
لحافظون طيب كيف احنا نحفظ القران هل يكفي
ان اتشدق واقول ان هذا لغه القران الكريم
وانا لا اقرا القران وانا لا اجود القران
وانا لا ارتل وانا لا امارس هذه اللغه
يعني كيف ممكن يضمن عنصر الحيويه والوجود
لهذه اللغه لان لغه تمارس هذه اللغه كان
اجتماعي اللغه كان اجتماعيه يعني يحيى
وينمو على السنه المتحدثين اذا لم نتكلم
ولا نمارس اللغه ستموت هذه اللغه يعني انا
لما قلت انا لا احب العربيه لان اللغه هذه
لها كاركتير يعني انا لما كنت ادرس لما
ادخل على الطلبه بالجنس كانوا يجوني
يسلمون عليه همم هم يعتقدون ان انا ادرس
ادب انجليزي لاني لابسه لان حتى تصورنا في
صوره نمطيه انه مدرسه العربي في كاركتير
كان هذه اللغه مباركه اولها
في شيء في حاله لهذه اللغه فيها ثقل وفيها
كذا ليست قريبه من الناس انا اريد يعني
همي ان يصادق اللغه ان تكون هذه لغه حياه
طيب ملزقات المطر مثل فنجان القهوه اروين
يعني الامر لم يعد مختصرا فقط على المجتمع
اتحدث عن مواقع التواصل اليوم اتذكر
الاستماع
حبيت هذه الالتقاطك لا انا قلت هذا الكلام
سابقا لان انا قرا اليوم الاعلام الجديد
قاعد يسحب البساط من الاعلام التقليدي
وانا اكره هذه الكلمه عروش الاعلام
التقليدي هزت شئنا اما بيننا لما انا اقول
الفضاء الازرق كما يقول الدكتور عبد الله
الغزاوي وهو مفكر كبير يكتب على تويتر
ويقول ان التويتر هذا كشف وفضح همم المشهد
الان انا كيف اعرف انه الناس كيف يفكرون
الجيل كيف يفكر عبر التويتر صح لان
التويتر هذه يعني احداثيات في التواصل
الاجتماعي احنا نقرا المشهد من خلال
الوسائل هذه بالعكس انا اقول انه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هذه كشفت لنا مستوى لان
في ناس يناظرون في ناس همم يعني مزيفين في
ناس همم يعني يتاجرون بمعاناه معينه
بتنظير معين لون شاي ويطبقون شاي وسائل
التواصل الان بين يدينا بالعكس هي تعطي
مؤشرات جدا مذهله هؤلاء الناس احنا ما كنا
نعرفهم نعرفهم باشاراتهم بتغريدات فاذن
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مثل الترمومتر خلينا نقول اللي يعطينا
حراره الشارع قياس معين همم اعتقد ان هذه
الفضاءات همم رغم طبعا استخدامها لكن هي
جدا مهمه اسال رغم ان المفكرين والمثقفين
والمهتمين باللغه لا يدخلونها
ويتعالون على هذه بس انا اعتقد انخراط في
هذه الوسائل جدا مهمه لان هي قاعده
للناس نقرب للغه هذه اللغه المقعره لغه
القواميس يجب ان تنزل الى الشارع
لا نحن محتاجين قوانيس يعني لازم يكون في
تحديث وفروين يبدو انه نحن نحتاج كمان
القاموس الفهم معنى اسمك يعني انا لا عندي
فضول لما اسمع باي اعلاميه في الوسط او اي
شخص يحمل نفس الاسم ما معنى اسمك ودلالاته
الاسم طبعا يختاروا لي اياها يعني
اسمي تيمنا بجدتي
هو اسم همم ليه عده معاني في الثقافات
فروين بالفارسيه احد منازل القبر نجم
الثريا او البابيون الفراشه او
بروين هو كثير العطاء كثيره الخير في
اللغه الكرديه او التركيه همم شكرا جزيلا
نورتينا في الاستديو شكرا لكم
شكرا شكرا نورتيني